okay so the League of Shadows story in
Detective Comics is man it's probably
one of the best things come at DC
rebirth this story is amazing now
admittedly before we get into this I
don't know very much about the character
of orphan really all I know it's kind of
what's thrown in here I really didn't
read like Batman Incorporated really
didn't read a lot of Batman before the
new 52 started and when it came to the
new 52 there really wasn't a whole lot
about her character at least as far as I
was able to tell there was some but
there were a lot of things I didn't
really read it wasn't really until
rebirth there was really kind of like
Snyder's run on Batman that I read but
you know until rebirth it wasn't that I
got really involved in the Batman mythos
so we're gonna try to explain her
character as best we can as we go
through this but I think we'll be able
to get the point across for the most
part but initially this picks up with a
group called the League of Shadows led
by Lady Shiva now this is actually kind
of a new thing when it comes to DC and
the reason why is because of the fact
that historically speaking there was a
League of Shadows so to speak but it was
really a name that was given to like the
League of Assassins the League of
Assassins went by a lot of different
aliases and one of them was the League
of Shadows because they were a group
that was so well hidden and you wouldn't
know they were there until they struck
now Lady Shiva herself before the new 52
was really more like a taskmaster esque
kind of character in DC Comics
resistance a that was a taskmaster and
Marvel is like a villain and people will
fight against him he's really more of a
guy that people go to for like training
and different things like that that's
really what Lady Shiva was in a lot of
different ways she was a character who
had prodigious martial-arts skills she
crossed paths with the League of
Assassins on several occasions for the
most part she was a character that DC
would interject when the story called
for it so like after the events of a
knife fall for example when Batman's
back was broken he went to Lady Shiva
and she basically we taught him how to
use the skills and how to function as a
prodigious fighter following his back
being broke in order to basically reown
his skills so the League of Shadows as
we see them here is really more of a
group that's actually kind of rolled
over from Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy in terms of how it
functions and the reason why will
actually be made over the course of this
video as we start to get into it but at
this point the story really starts to
focus a lot on orphan now as far as
Cassandra Kane goes her whole run with
you know being a being a villain and I
guess being a part of the bat family and
so on is really more tied to the idea
that and again I'm a little fuzzy on
this in terms of you know pre new 52
versus new 52 but as far as I'm aware
was a character who was just trained to
be an excellent fighter her father was a
guy who went by the name of orphan his
name of course was David Kane but he
taught her to communicate through body
language as opposed to normal speech and
that's the reason why whenever you go
through Batman comics in DC rebirth or
you read a story that has the character
of orphan in it she always speaks in
broken English she uses like quick
phrases different things like that if
she speaks it kind of an ad hoc way when
someone says hey are you awake she'll
see it she'll say yes awake
she won't say yes I am awake she'll
somebody just say yes awake because for
her she's just communicating the main
points yes and she's awake so again
that's really kind of how a character
talks and it actually adds a pretty cool
element to her because it's almost like
we as the reader have to kind of get a
better idea of what it is that she's
saying now the other half of this is
that orphan really takes your name from
the idea that she was never really told
who her mother was and her father had
died you know David Cain had been killed
and so because of that she was very much
in orphan so she was both caring on her
father's mantle as well as literally
recognizing the fact that she had no
genuine parents and so because of this
she's really very much a character who's
alone in a lot of different ways now
when you pair this with the fact that
she was a very close friend of Stephanie
Brown spoiler who had basically vacated
the bat family after Tim Drake had you
know supposedly died and the first
Detective Comics story in DC rebirth
this basically was kind of left to
orphan let's Cassandra in a state where
she just felt isolated and removed from
everything and so all she does is really
spend all her time just training in the
mudroom which is basically the training
area you know kind of like the Danger
Room so to speak of the bat family now
the issue with this is that this
consistently removes her away from the
human element and that's something that
she's always struggled with her
character is always struggled with the
idea of being part and parcel to
humanity gaining a reattachment to
people so it would almost be like if you
raised a child in a feral State and then
tried to reintegrate that child in a
society only for that child to try to
keep itself removed from society it
would never really be integrated wholly
and that's really what the bat family
does the bat family is more as just as
much about having her become a
legitimate member of the team and
fighting crime as it is about trying to
integrate her into normal society and
allowing her to live a normal life but
what we end up doing is we actually pick
up a bat man you know he's kind of going
around the city trying to find out her
trying to gain a meeting with Mayor
Haiti home to find out that mayor Haiti
has basically been impaled stabbed with
various swords and his pen
to a wall now mayor Haiti basically says
this was done by the League of Shadows
and this is really kind of cool because
what we end up doing here is once the
cops break in and they of course believe
that that man was the one that started
all this we basically transition over to
Jacob Kane to the father of that woman
now again for those of you guys who are
new to the whole Batman story so far
Jacob was a guy who was a leader of a
group called the colony and the colony
was basically the first villain the
first villain group that we had seen in
Detective Comics as part of DC rebirth
and the idea was that the colony had
basically moved into Gotham with the
intention of taking out Batman
hijacking all of this technology
absorbing that technology and creating
an army of Batman hence the reason why
the story is called Detective Comics
rebirth rise of the Batman because it's
their goal to basically replace Batman
and create an army of Batman now in
terms of what the motivation was at the
time it really seemed to be more of this
idea that you know Jacob was a very
militaristic guy he was a guy who
basically thought that Batman wasn't
doing an adequate job and he could do
would do a better job than that but
following the presumed death of Tim
Drake and the fact that Jacob had been
taken prisoner he's basically just kind
of been a background character
occasionally if he would talk to his
daughter Batwoman he would try to you
know speak with her he would basically
get through to her from time to time it
was one of the people who had basically
motivated her to kind of become more of
a hero than she was before but for the
most part it was always through a glass
window there was really no development
for his character he was just kind of
sitting in stasis what this does is it
tells us the entire motivation behind
the colony stepping into Gotham City and
trying to remove that man take over his
technology and create an army of Batman
was because of the League of Shadows
because the League of Shadows is this
extremely dangerous subset of the League
of Assassins that simply just cannot be
controlled by conventional means and
simply just want to raise the world and
that's the crazy thing about this is
because what Jacobs basically telling
Batman is you've never faced a threat
like this you've never gone against
anyone like this before if you keep this
up if you do not leave if you do not
abandon your city you're going to die
and it's really kind of crazy because
the way the League of Shadows is
depicted here is that they're
effectively a force of nature
right like you can't stop a hurricane
any more than you can stop the Sun
rising and so it's like you know with
the League of Shadows they just come
swooping in to someplace and they just
start eradicating things they just you
know tear through Gotham like a plague
and so what is up happening here really
kind of a first stage of this attack
is on the Gotham News and what is up
happening is a couple of the anchors
begin showing symptoms of the Joker
toxin after which they promptly die and
that's where the panic begins to come
into play because people don't know if
it's the League of Shadows or if it's
the Joker returning now because of the
fact that Batman doesn't believe the
League of Shadows exists because the
rest of that family takes their lead
from Batman ultimately the idea as well
as just the Joker toxin coming back
that's all it is the Joker is launching
an attack now again this is kind of cool
because this is DC kind of setting the
stage for the return of the Joker saying
hey lest we forget
the Joker's still around the Joker's
still at large no one knows where he is
he's just running around which of course
sets the stage for the revelation of who
the three Joker's are which is the story
then I'm dying for us to be able to get
I'm so surprised that it took so long
but it's going to make it all the
sweeter when the story comes out because
it's all the anticipation and all the
excitement that builds up for the whole
thing but the fact remains that
ultimately this leads to the bat family
learning about an attack and atom Square
Park and of course this again is really
cool because what this tells us is that
the League of Shadows is extremely smart
and how they function which is whole
outbreak in Adams Park ah the indication
here seems to be that people are
succumbing to the Joker toxin source of
you know the Joker's struck Adams Park
or something along those lines when the
bat family responds these folks are
pretending they're faking they are all
members of the League of Shadows and
they all begin attacking the Batman
leaned up from here we jump back to the
past and we actually take up with Ra's
al Ghul and this is basically DC saying
hey look here is the nature of the
League of Shadows that you have the
League of Assassins created by Ra's al
Ghul and then you have the League of
Shadows which is run by Lady Shiva now
what this does is show us that there's a
little bit of difficulty a little bit of
animosity between the two but we don't
know how far back it goes it'll be
explained over the course of the story
but at the moment right now we don't
know how far back they go we don't know
why the League of Shadows exists we
don't know why it's at odds with the
League of Assassins but what we do know
is they are prodigious and they are far
beyond the League of Assassins because
of the fact that Ra's al Ghul calls
those guys in and Lady Sheba takes out
every last one of them now with regards
to the bat family going against these
various members of the League of Shadows
this is pretty straightforward I mean
it's really just kind of them fending
off and doing what they can it's Batman
basically saying hey look you know we
can't kill them we have to incapacitate
them and therein lies the weakness of
the bat family and that's really what it
is the League of Shadows
counting on when you're going against
Batman Batman doesn't kill and so you
all you have to do is really be willing
to just go grab a hostage somewhere I'll
go put a bomb in the building and say
hey if you come over here I will blow up
this entire building and kill everybody
in it that gives you an instant upper
hand on Batman now of course it doesn't
really matter anyway because Batman
comics always has Batman coming out on
top and even Batman fans will tell you
well of course Batman would win because
he's Batman so again it's one of these
cool kind of a kind of funny situations
but ultimately this again also shows us
that orphan is extremely good at what
she does as she's basically just kind of
a prodigious fighter and has a natural
aptitude for it because of the fact that
while everybody else is fighting the
League of Shadows she's fighting them as
well but she also notices Lady Shiva on
a rooftop and so once she goes to
confront Lady Shiva really orphans kind
of taunted about the idea that hey look
you know you're just fighting you know
you're not dealing killing blows when
you could win and that's really kind of
the nature of this discussion that's
really the kind of point that Lady Shiva
is hitting home that ultimately orphan
does not really have what it takes to
win because she's not really willing to
kill when it comes down to it ultimately
her weakness will be her willingness to
allow other people to live now of course
with Batman arriving on the scene with
the intention of taking down Lady Shiva
this again really shows us that a lot of
this stuff with regards to classic DC
doesn't apply anymore for example again
we had talked about how Lady Shiva had
basically helped Batman regain the use
of his fighting abilities after he had a
had his back broken by Bane and this
encounter they don't know each other
they've never met before now the way
that this was going to be done is
actually going to explain a possible
reason for this that in fact they had
met before but Batman doesn't realize it
he doesn't remember it there'll be an
explanation for why that's the case so
it's really do you see kind of toying
kind of going on a possibility of like
flow you know maybe they had that before
and depending on the popularity of this
story we'll flush that out or we'll just
act like they're meeting for the very
first time again this is one of those
walking the middle lines kind of on the
precipice sort of things and this is
what DC does with with the Batman
landscape remember Batman so popular is
really one of the most popular
characters if not the most popular
character among color book readers
within the realm of DC and so because of
that with the whole you know kind of
combining classic Batman with the new 52
Batman Thea when new 52 first launched
DC said oh yeah knife all happened
because it's Batman's signature story
it's like one of the most popular
stories he ever had you know these
classic stories happen sure but DC
tested the
well let's introduce Bing and if the
return of Bane is successful if people
love it then we'll bring back into
fruition the idea that Vayne broke
Batman's back at some point along line
so again it's really one of these these
things that DC's kind of toying with
with the possibilities but the other
half of this is that because the police
had arrived on the scene and they had
witnessed Batman in the same room as
mayor Haiti who in turn was impaled what
this is done is effectively turned
Batman into a vigilante and they're mine
Batman's a villain Batman is a bad guy
you know he's the one who's responsible
for killing mayor Haiti proper now of
course at the time Commissioner Gordon
was basically being held in protective
custody but a portion of Renee Montoya
alongside that woman and Batman
access Jim Gordon of course Rey Montoya
is the way in which they're able to do
this because remember Renee Montoya is
one of the few cops out there who is an
ally of the bat family through that
woman and so because of that she knows
good and well that Batman didn't kill
mayor hate but she also recognizes that
Batman in Commissioner Gordon kind of
had these back-channel communications
that allow them to be able to converse
with one another and figure things out
without the entire city going to pot and
so with Batman talking to Jim Gordon the
question that they have is what's the
bigger picture here what in the world is
going on the problem is that they can't
quite figure out everything that's
happening but the idea of having Jim
Gordon brought into the in it end of the
situation comes by way of the fact that
the current deputy mayor wants to lock
down the city of Gotham and keep anybody
from leaving well what this would do is
it would be equivalent to putting people
in a room and then gassing the room it
makes them sitting ducks
and so Batman's response is you are Jim
Gordon you're the Commissioner you have
experience your word is respected even
if it's not guaranteed to be heard it
carries more weight than most please go
talk to the deputy mayor and have Gotham
City evacuated it's really the best they
can do under this particular situation
and so while this is happening what we
end up doing is basically having a you
know Batman return to Gotham City and we
actually have him coming into direct
conflict with orphan now the reason why
this is the case is because of the fact
that orphaned is effectively on a
mission to go and find her mother but
orphan is also in a state where she's
really walking the line between who she
wants to be and who she is remember she
was trained to be an assassin she was
very much like Damian Wayne and the
sense that she was trained to be a
killer that was her job go be a child
killer now this was done to basically
prove that child killers are you know
are something that can work that they're
actually
the best kind of assassins because who
would expect the kind little
nine-year-old girl to be the one who's
going to do UN but you know it's also
this idea that she's very much a broken
person and so with her also kind of
reconciling the feelings that she's
trying to live a normal life in the end
she doesn't see Batman as a person is
trying to help her restore herself as a
normal person she sees Batman who's a
person that's in the way of her getting
to her mother to get some answers to
some questions that she has now for us
the cool thing about this is that
previously in the story the question was
asked by that woman towards that man if
Batman fought orphaned what would happen
would she win and Batman's response was
of course she would win she's just
better at fighting than I am which is
really kind of cool because that's
exactly what happens I mean when Batman
goes against orphan she easily
overpowers him it might be a scenario of
Batman pulling punches it might be a
scenario of him saying well you know I'm
not gonna fight her with full extent of
my abilities but even the fact that he
would sit down and say yes if I fought
her I would lose means Bruce Wayne
recognizes how capable of a fighter she
is more so than that it's also the idea
that Batman's surrounding himself with
people who are capable regardless of
whether they can beat him or not that is
really creating the best kind of that
family possible with no concern as to
whether or not he could die by one of
the hands of these people if they lost
their mind against him and so because of
this Cassandra comes into direct
conflict with her mama where she ends up
meeting Lady Shiva and the funny thing
about this is that it's again kind of
like round two so to speak between the
two of these these characters fighting
but the idea is that orphan is looking
for answers but Lady Shiva gives none
instead she says let's test what you're
capable of let's see what kind of a
fighter you are and ultimately she's
easily subdued yet again because again
she's not really fighting with her heart
of hearts she's not really fighting with
any measure of inner peace she's
fighting with inner turmoil she's in an
emotional state and so this really kind
of strikes the final blow and the reason
why is because of the fact that orphan
will actually be picked up by a friend
of source who will basically sort of
return her back to his state of normalcy
and give her a better idea of where she
belongs but from this point what we do
is we actually pick up in the Batcave of
course the reason being because of the
fact that Batman had been talking to
Alfred only to hear a disturbance over
the radio indicating that Alfred had
been incapacitated more so than that
that woman Clayface orphan there is all
basically defeated by the League of
Shadows alongside that wing and so on so
the bat family is systematically being
taken down by the leak and that's what
makes this so cool is because we rarely
ever see stories where the entire bat
family is just wholly incapacitated well
there's no contest that's what makes
this so interesting is because again
it's DC hitting home at the idea that
the League of Shadows is serious
business with regards to Batman
returning to the Batcave and then
running into Ra's al Ghul again this is
kind of a funny scenario because what
this does is this DC kind of invoking
this idea that Batman's mind has been
meddled with now this is something that
could be very divisive among fans there
are those who could say well god this is
just lazy storytelling or there are
those you could say it's actually a
really good idea I personally think it's
a genius idea because what it does is it
opens the door for DC to do virtually
anything they want to and the reason why
is because again referencing classic
Batman versus new 52 Batman DC kind of
had to work their way in they kind of
had to sort of add things and kind of do
what they wanted to but they had to test
the waters to make sure it worked for
example the original hush storyline took
place in classic DC hush was rolled over
into the new 52 Batman
during Batman eternal but there was no
guarantee that that was going to be
successful and even then they were only
limited to hush they were limited to
storylines but this discussion between
Ra's al Ghul and Batman Batman basically
says look you told me about the League
of Shadows at some point along the line
but Ra's al Ghul's question is did I
really if I did then when did I tell you
that when did I give you this
information so Batman's basically
claiming to remember something that he
couldn't have possibly remembered and
this is when Ra's al Ghul basically says
the reason why you don't remember it is
because I wiped your mind so you
wouldn't remember it that at some point
along the line you came across my League
of Assassins and my League of Shadows
that you faced against the League of
Shadows you were able to hold your own
on a couple of occasions you were
defeated you know on several occasions
but each time you came to learn about
them and I didn't want you to so I
simply use magic to wipe your mind of
their existence now again this is kind
of a divisive thing because there are
some folks who would say that they
really like it there are some folks who
say they won't but what this does is it
basically leads to the question if this
is what was wiped from the mind of Bruce
Wayne what else has been wiped from his
own mind which means now it allows DC to
go back and grab all these different
concepts from classic DC small stuff
itty-bitty things this is almost kind of
like a Batman equivalent of Superman
reborn right like Superman reborn gave
us this whole new origin for the
character of Superman this this little
aspect of having Batman's mind wife
having his memories altered and then
going back and regaining what these
memories were basically means that DC
can say okay now here is the full Batman
here's everything that's ever happened
to him as far as DC rebirth is concerned
it allows them to add all kinds of
things in and basically blend classic
Batman with new 52 Batman giving us all
these great moments and great little
segments and so on and so forth so again
ultimately what happens is that when
Batman effectively frees Ra's al Ghul
after Ra's basically says look I can
give you the tools to bring down the
League of Shadows Ra's al Ghul
presumably in turned attached Batman
basically kind of subdues him using
somatic a source that basically
paralyzes him allowing him to hear
everything that's going on but not
allowing him to fight back now the
indication here is that Ra's al Ghul
does this on behalf of Batman but it's
really not him attacking him as a
villain it's him attacking him as an
ally basically saying look we're going
to put on the ruse we're going to put on
a show and this comes to fruition when
Lady Shiva and the League of Shadows
arrives and Ra's al Ghul says hey look
per our agreement here is Batman now at
this point it's also the idea that Jacob
Kane has been released now of course
Jacob Kane having been released came by
way of colony pawn of course remember
basically the second-in-command of Jacob
during the first Detective Comics story
who managed to make his escape at the
end of those event and has just kind of
been sitting out in no-man's land during
the entirety of the Batman Detective
Comics stories following that first
particular arc but him freeing Jacob
basically means that now the entirety of
the colony has returned and is back
under the control of Jacob now the role
that this plays is actually pretty
limited in this story it's really this
idea that Jacob basically says look our
job here is to eliminate the League of
Shadows after that we will vanish and
will we muster our forces and we'll do
whatever it is that we're going to do
next
but the freeing of Jacob Kane also came
with the arrival of a guy named Ulysses
Hadrian Armstrong now Ulysses is kind of
like this this brain guy with regards to
to the colony and he's actually got a
pretty genius idea in terms of what it
is he's going to do to defeat the League
of Shadows albeit a very questionable
thing the problem with this is that when
the question is asked you know how the
League of Shadows is going to be
incapacitated the colony with their
numbers are so small as they are now
can't do it on their own and so what is
it happening is the emphasis for the
defeat of the League of Shadows switches
away from the colony and the bat family
and focuses solely on portion until
again this is pretty
because with you know that woman and
with that wing and with Azrael basically
all being held captive by the League of
Shadows as well as Batman having been
subdued orphan is literally a one-woman
army she's taking on massive numbers of
the League of Shadows all over the city
of Gotham and taking every last one of
them out now the motivation behind this
and the reason why is because of the
fact did we actually jump back about two
hours ago so shortly after it was she
had that she had been defeated by Lady
Shiva the second time and thrown down
into a sewer and we end up finding out
that orphan was basically rescued by one
of the girls who works in you know works
in the ballet and this girl began
telling orphan about the story that she
was reading and the story was basically
about a girl who was torn between two
worlds but she was a normal human being
she had normal thoughts and normal
feelings and emotions but as a child
she'd been told you are not human you
are a tool to be used and so this
knowledge conflicted with her own
emotion and it basically put her in a
scenario where she didn't know who she
was supposed to be or what she was
supposed to be about now this is
designed to directly mirror the nature
of orphan innocence did orphan is a girl
of two worlds she's from world of
assassins where she's also from a world
where she's trying to understand what it
means to be a normal human and so what
does does is it basically motivates
orphan it basically says look no one can
tell you what your destiny is no one can
tell you what your fate is no one can
tell you who you're supposed to be you
have to figure that out on your own and
that's exactly what she does she says
look I have these tools I have these
tools that make me a prodigious assassin
but they don't define me they don't make
me who I am I make myself Who I am the
path that I choose is what it is that
defines me this is kind of kind of
ironic here because this is what
Batman's been telling her the entire
time but it's an incoming book
representation of what it is it always
happens with us right like it's when
somebody some kind of a third party
somebody that has no vested interest in
us shows up and says hey look maybe you
shouldn't do that or maybe you should
think about things this way we're more
likely to take it to heart because from
them is advice whereas from a parent
it's them telling us what to do you know
in a game it's kind of a little bit of a
funny scenario here but for whatever
reason this girl was able to reach to
orphan who in turn embrace her identity
and braced her skills and basically to
started crushing the entirety of the
League of Shadows because she is in
effect one of the world's greatest
fighters now of course this scenario
comes directly with her going against
Lady Shiva and of course what this also
does is lead
we put orphan freeing the rest of the
bass family with the rest of that family
going against Lady Shiva as well now
some of the individuals are we meet are
immediately removed from the equation
for example Batwoman you know she has
sustained some injuries she'd been
stabbed a few times she was basically
bleeding out Azrael much the same way
and so if never kind of removed from the
equation pretty fast and so this is
really designed to be a fight that was
going to emphasize and focus almost
solely on the bat family but food
regards to Ulysses the kind of side
Triforce I can focus on his character he
actually has this really genius idea and
what he done is he sat down and he had
basically engineered this by eleven and
this Maya woman was going to serve a
purpose of basically eradicating you
know everything underground wherever it
is if he put it he was basically going
to serve the purpose of being like
napalm with intelligence and so what he
says here is that the League of Shadows
is all basically converged into one
singular location underground and sure
the bat families down there but at the
end of the day you know what's the death
of a handful of people if it means that
we get to save thousands in the process
and so again it's one of these
utilitarian philosophies the good of the
many outweigh the needs of the few I
guess the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few and that's true you
have to sacrifice the few in order to
make sure that the needs of the many are
met and that's the case is being made
here sacrifice the back family so that
thousands and millions of people across
Gotham City will be fine and they'll
continue to live the problem with this
is of course Jacob came steps in and
says no my daughter's down there so you
are not going to kill the bad family so
that that that scenarios kind of held
off what we also end up finding out here
is that what we don't know the exact
motivation behind it ultimately Lady
Shiva had a very good reason for turning
against Ra's al Ghul and it didn't seem
like it was a selfish thing it didn't
seem like it was her basically saying oh
hey I just want to be you know a person
that leads my own group the Ra's al Ghul
was up to something extremely nefarious
and it was in the interest of the League
of Shadows to basically try to eliminate
all the influence that Ra's al Ghul had
and then take out Ra's al Ghul himself
so we don't know if we're ours is in the
midst of basically plotting world
domination we don't know if he's in the
midst of attempting to eliminate all
life on Earth and the League of Shadows
was going to take out Gotham City in
order to keep that from happening we
don't know but it seems like there was a
much greater motivation for Lady Shiva
than was initially put on and so because
of this Lady Shiva
before she can actually give the answer
to orphan it's basically shot from
behind by Ra's al Ghul after which her
body is collected and taken by Ra's
instead
that family's basically kind of left to
do their own thing but as everything
begins to wrap up again this is DC kind
of leaving the door open because it's
Batman asking the question look if my
mind was altered by Ra's al Ghul and
there are things that I'll remember then
what else do I not remember what else
have I been forced to forget you know
what else might exist out there for me
so again it's basically gets anyway miss
idea that we still have a lot of great
stories coming down the pipe with Batman
for example the whole idea of Batman
being the God of knowledge the Batman
going in and learning about the three
Joker's this may very well be an aspect
of what it is that he's been made to
forget and if he's able to recall it the
Batman
suddenly jumps into the question of who
are the three Joker's then we get into
like the war of jokes and riddles and so
on and so forth but any event if you
guys are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
[Music]
[Applause]